Transcription: Gabriella Kikidi
Relecteur: Eleni Tziafa
On préférait qu’elle nous évite.
Alors, on ne regarde pas, on écoute pas.
On ne parle pas.
De tout ce qui pourrait
nous rapprocher d’elle.
Et pourtant, elle viendra inévitablement.
Nous sommes tous de passage.
Tout est un permanent facile à admettre
pour les fleurs, pour les papillons,
mais beaucoup moins
pour les gens que l’on aime.
Le 9 avril 2015, après avoir passé
plusieurs mois à l’hôpital avec lui,
sans comprendre ce qui lui arrivait
la veille de faire un nom,
mon petit garçon, Gaspard,
est mort dans mes bras.
Je n’ai pas de mots pour vous dire
ce que j’ai ressenti à ce moment là.
Dans sa petite chambre de réanimation,
j’ai poussé un cri,
sorti du plus profond de moi même,
tout mon corps hurlait
de colère, de désespoir.
Ce n'était pas possible, pas mon Gaspard.
Je me suis effondrée.
À ce moment là , tout s’effondre.
On ne peut rien contre la mort,
elle est brutale, irréversible.
Je vivais la première phase du deuil,
celle qu'on appelle la phase du choc.
Et il était violent.
Quelques jours plus tard,
il y a eu l’enterrement.
À notre demande, tout le monde
est venu habillé en couleur.
Ce sont trois amis
qui ont animé la cérémonie.
On avait vraiment envie que ce soit
un moment qui nous ressemble
et qui nous évoque aussi
l’univers d’enfants de Gaspard.
Je suis institutrice
et les élèves de mon école
nous avons envoyé des dessins de soutien
que l’on a épinglés à des fils
dans la salle de cérémonie.
Famille et amis sont venus
chanter, lire des poèmes,
jouer de la musique.
Le moment était si douloureux
et l’amour tellement présent
en même temps.
Nous ne voulions pas de fleurs coupées,
mais des plantes bien vivantes
qui ont pris racine sur sa tombe
et refleurissent chaque printemps
autour de sa petite photo au cimetière,
il y a de la vie et c’est
ce qu’on voulait.
Après l’enterrement,
famille et amis sont repartis.
À l’intérieur je vivais
une véritable tempête émotionnelle.
J'avais l'impression d'être
dans une machine à laver.
Je guettait partout un signe
qui puisse me raccrocher à lui.
Sa turbulette me servait
de taie d’oreiller.
C’était la deuxième phase du deuil,
celle qu’on appelle la phase de recherche
qui commençait.
Je souffrais, et mon couple
aussi risquait de souffrir.
Avec Guillaume, mon compagnon,
nous avions des réactions différentes.
Moi, j’avais davantage besoin de parler
et lui avait besoin d’être dans l’action.
Chacun de nous portait
sa propre culpabilité.
Moi, je revoyais souvent la scène
du décès de Gaspard à l’hôpital
et j’imaginais tout ce que j’aurais pu
faire pour que ça n’arrive pas.
Guillaume culpabilisait énormément
d’être parti travailler
et de ne pas être arrivé
à temps cette nuit là.
Deux mois après le décès de Gaspard,
nous avons décidé de suivre
des séances de EMDR.
C’est une thérapie brève qui consiste
à dissocier les émotions
des souvenirs auxquels
elles sont attachées
et de stopper les souvenirs
qui reviennent en boucle.
Ça a été très efficace et ça nous a permis
de mieux comprendre l’autre
dans sa façon de vivre son deuil.
Pourtant, la colère,
la tristesse, la culpabilité,
le manque étaient parfois si intenses
que j’ai pensé plusieurs fois mourir
plutôt que de devoir supporter ça.
C’est la troisième phase du deuil,
c’est la plus longue,
celle qu’on appelle
la phase de déstructuration,
et elle entraîne souvent
un vécu dépressif.
Heureusement, une amie nous a offert
le livre de Christophe Fauré,
« Vivre le deuil au jour le jour ».
Le psychiatre insiste sur le fait
que cette phase fait
bien partie d’un processus.
Le livre décrivait exactement
ce que nous ressentions.
Ça nous a donné des repères.
Ça nous a permis de comprendre
que ce qu’on traversait était douloureux,
mais que c’était normal de passer par là.
Christophe Fauré compare la brûlure,
enfin, la blessure à une brûlure.
On peut choisir de ne pas la regarder et
de laisser le temps cicatriser la plaie,
et on peut aussi choisir
d’en prendre soin,
d’y mettre de la pommade,
d’y apposer des bandages.
J’avais vraiment besoin
de prendre soin de ma blessure.
Nous avons toujours été
très entourés et là,
nous en avions d’autant plus besoin.
Dans le deuil, on peut
avoir tendance à s’isoler,
se renfermer par peur de gêner les autres,
d'étaler notre tristesse et qu'à terme,
plus personne ne veuille nous côtoyer.
Nous avons craint ce fossé
avec nos proches.
Quand on allait voir des copains,
ils étaient contents et désemparés aussi.
Comment reçoit ressentons
ces amis lorsqu’ils vont si mal ?
Peut-être avez vous déjà ressenti
cette impression d’être tellement démuni ?
Mais nous ne voulions pas
en faire un tabou.
Nous en parlions de nous mêmes,
des photos de Gaspard
sont accrochées dans la maison,
ça peut inviter à la discussion.
Et lorsque des proches me demandaient
comment ils pouvaient m’en parler
sans que ça me gêne,
je leur répondais de me demander
simplement comment je me sentais
plutôt qu’un simple « Salut, ça va ! »,
avec lequel je me sentais
souvent mal à l’aise.
Ainsi, je pouvais répondre
avec la précision qui me convenait
et je me sentais prise en compte.
Dans les premières années,
on a beaucoup parlé
de ce qu’on traversait,
des expériences de deuil de chacun,
des croyances autour de la mort.
On s’est rendu compte
que ça nous faisait du bien,
mais que ça faisait aussi
du bien à notre entourage.
Ça permettait de démystifier
un peu le sujet.
On a beaucoup ri aussi d’ailleurs,
et on en a même culpabilisé.
En étant moins triste,
j’avais peur d’oublier Gaspard.
La douleur était la seule chose
qui me raccrochait à la vie.
Pourtant, si j’ai
un seul conseil à donner,
vivez les moments de joie
lorsqu’ils arrivent,
ils n’enlèvent rien à la peine.
Chaque moment de joie est
précieux et bon à prendre.
On ne fait pas son deuil, on le traverse.
On vit avec.
Au fil des mois, les vagues
finissent par se passer.
Elles sont encore fortes,
mais reviennent moins souvent.
Avec Guillaume à plusieurs reprises,
on a eu envie de mettre en place
des rituels qui nous parlaient
et de guider notre entourage
sur l’attitude à avoir
avec les personnes en deuil.
Avec ses rituels, comme Gaspard est décédé
la veille de son premier anniversaire,
chaque année, il renaît en quelque sorte
le lendemain de sa mort.
Pour fêter ses anniversaires, on invite
tous les deux ans famille et amis,
à venir passer un week end à sa mémoire.
On a par exemple planté un olivier
pour enraciner le fait qu’il sera
toujours présent parmi nous.
On a fabriqué une montgolfière
pour symboliser l’envol
et l’envie qu’on avait
aussi de le laisser partir.
On a appris des chants,
organiser des ateliers de discussion.
J’avais aussi vraiment besoin
de comprendre comment les événements vécus
par les uns peuvent impacter
la vie des autres.
Malgré tout, je me sentais
parfois très seule,
comme si nous étions
les seuls à vivre ce deuil.
Pourtant, une étude du CRÉDOC montre
que plus de 5 mille familles par an
vivent la perte d’un enfant
et qu’un Français sur quatre
se sent en deuil d’un être cher.
Alors, pourquoi n’en
parle-t-on pas davantage ?
Lorsque Gaspard est mort,
les soignants en face de moi
semblaient figés.
Ils n'avaient pas de mots.
J’ai compris plus tard
qu’ils n’étaient pas
formés à gérer la mort,
mais simplement à gérer la vie.
La mort de Gaspard était
un échec pour eux.
Les pompes funèbres elles-mêmes
ne sont pas toujours formées.
Lorsque les portes
du frigo funéraire se referment,
vous vous retrouvez seuls
face à vous même.
Le deuil et l’expérience de vie
la plus partagée
est, paradoxalement, la plus taboue.
Il existe un ministère de la Santé,
mais pas de ministère
de la Mort et du Deuil.
Comme si la mort n’existait pas,
qu’elle ne faisait pas partie
de notre société,
ce qui serait une bonne nouvelle,
surtout en ce moment.
Mais, malheureusement,
ce n’est pas le cas.
Et le déni coûte cher
émotionnellement et financièrement,
car en réalité,
de nombreux endeuillés restent
en arrêt de travail pendant longtemps.
Un an et demi après la mort de Gaspard,
j’ai eu envie de rencontrer des personnes
qui avaient vécu la même chose que nous
et de m’enrichir de leurs témoignages.
J’avais envie que ce soit filmé
pour que ça serve aussi à d’autres
qui, comme moi, se sentaient désemparés.
Je suis parti à pied dans la Drôme
avec un âne et des amis
pour me montrer le chemin.
Nous avons rencontré des parents
qui avaient perdu un enfant
et qui pouvaient témoigner
de leur expérience de manière inspirante.
De ce voyage initiatique est né le film
documentaire « Et je choisis de vivre »
Afin qu’ils puissent voir le jour,
nous sommes partis
à la recherche de producteurs,
mais autant vous dire que le sujet
n’était pas très vendeur.
Alors avec mes amis réalisateurs,
Nans Thomassey et Damien Boyer,
nous avons décidé de lancer une campagne
de financement participatif
et à notre grande surprise,
ça a été la deuxième
plus grande levée de fonds
pour un film documentaire.
Il a finalement pu être diffusé
dans de nombreuses salles de cinéma
grâce à des associations
qui accompagnent la fin de vie et le deuil
et à des ambassadeurs
qui avaient eu vent du projet
et l’ont colportée dans leur cinéma.
Et il a même été diffusé à la télévision.
On a eu beaucoup de critiques positives
de la part des personnes
endeuillées ou non,
parce que nous sommes tous concernés.
Cet incroyable élan
m’a montré à quel point
le besoin de parler
de ce sujet était partagé.
On a reçu de nombreux commentaires,
vous pouvez revoir ici quelques-uns.
J’ai reçu tellement d’espoir,
de tendresse, de soutien, qu’à mon tour,
j’ai eu envie d’offrir ces cadeaux
à tous ceux qui ont perdu
celui ou celle qu’ils aimaient.
Avec l’équipe du film,
on a créé l’association
« Mieux traverser le deuil ».
C’est une plateforme numérique
avec beaucoup de ressources
pour que toutes les personnes endeuillées
puissent se sentir rapidement soutenues.
Elle relaye aussi la parole
de nombreuses associations
qui font un travail incroyable
sur tout le territoire
et qui sont trop souvent méconnues.
Dans ce deuil,
j’avais l’impression de partir
pour un véritable voyage intérieur
ou peut être le plus intense de ma vie.
J’étais terrifié à l’idée
de ne jamais en revenir
et en même temps,
j’avais le sentiment
que la mort de Gaspard
me faisait vivre
une vraie expérience spirituelle.
Je suis reconnaissante aujourd’hui
pour toutes les portes
que ça a pu m’ouvrir.
On dit que les vivants ferment
les yeux des morts
et que les morts ouvrent
les yeux des vivants.
Je n’ai pas choisi de vivre
du jour au lendemain,
ça n’a pas été un déclic.
J’ai simplement mis
un pied devant l’autre.
Au début, tête baissée pour ne pas voir
l’ampleur du chemin à parcourir,
j’ai mis chaque jour
en place une petite action
et un jour, je me suis rendu compte
que la lumière avait repris
plus de place que l’ombre dans ma vie.
Avec Guillaume, on a décidé
d’amener la vie à la maison.
Trois petits loups nous ont rejoints
et en plus notre quotidien
de leurs rires et de leurs cris.
Ils savent qu’ils ont un grand frère,
qu’ils ne verront jamais.
On en parle souvent,
on regarde des photos.
Ils aiment aller au cimetière.
Ils disent qu'ils vont arroser Gaspard.
Ce n'est pas un manque que l'on comble.
Il y a une place pour chaque enfant.
C'est simplement aller de l'avant
et choisir la vie qui continue.
Je suis sûr à présent
que je n’oublierai jamais Gaspard.
Je ne le cherche plus,
je le porte en moi
et l’amour que j’ai pour lui
est indestructible.
En fait, comme le dit Christophe Fauré,
on ne se détache pas
de la personne disparue.
On s'attache autrement.
C’est la 4e phase du deuil,
la phase de restructuration.
Je peux renouer un lien intime
et particulier avec Gaspard
et me tourner à nouveau vers l’extérieur.
Je vous ai parlé de ces quatre phases
et elles peuvent servir de balise,
mais elles n’interviennent pas
forcément dans un ordre linéaire
et n’ont pas non plus de durée déterminée.
A chacun son propre chemin.
Je rêve que le tabou se brise,
que l’on se parle ouvertement
de la fin de vie,
de la mort et du deuil.
Il existe par exemple la possibilité
d’organiser des cérémonies
ou des veillées à domicile,
de choisir un cercueil
ou une urne biodégradable,
de semer des fleurs
champêtres sur la tombe,
de faire intervenir un maître
de cérémonie laïque.
Ça peut être aussi
des rituels tout simples,
comme allumer une bougie
lors de retrouvailles en famille
pour une date anniversaire,
aller faire une balade
que vous aimiez faire ensemble.
Planter un arbre,
allez faire un goûter au cimetière.
Peut être écrire vous même ce que
vous souhaitez pour votre enterrement
et demander aux autres
ce qu’ils souhaitent.
Il y a plein de choses à imaginer,
à créer,  pour ramener du lien, du vivant,
de la beauté, et pour faire de ce passage
un moment sacré qui nous ressemble.
Et si vous connaissez
des personnes en deuil,
ne craignez pas de les déranger à pleurer.
Demandez leur simplement
comment ils se sentent.
Ils répondront à la mesure
de ce qui est bien pour eux sur le moment.
Ils apprécieront
votre présence, votre écoute.
Vous pouvez aussi amener
un petit plat, une plante.
Notez la date du décès pour envoyer
un petit message pour l’anniversaire.
Et surtout,
n’oubliez pas!
(Elle chant) Quand la vie est impitoyable,
nous tombe dessus.
On n’est que des pauvres diables,
broyés et déçus.
Alors, sans la tendresse
d’un cœur qui nous soutient.
Non, non, non, non.
On n’irait pas plus loin.
(Applaudissements)